YESTERDAY, WE SHOWED YOU HILLARY
CLINTON LEADING IN A
HEAD-TO-HEAD MATCHUP.
THE NUMBERS RELEASED TODAY ARE
NO BETTER.
66% OF LIKELY VOTERS SAID THEY
HAD AN UNFAVORABLE VIEW OF
DONALD TRUMP.
ABC NEWS HAS THAT NUMBER A
LITTLE HIGHER AT 70%.
55% THEY WOULD NEVER VOTE FOR
TRUMP.
THESE POLLS ADD TO WHAT HAS BEEN
A SYNONYMY OF NEGATIVE HEADLINES
FOR DONALD TRUMP, THE STATE OF
HIS CAMPAIGN, RESPONSE TO THE
ORLANDO MASSACRE, AND ONGOING
WAR WITH NEWS ORGANIZATIONS.
IT HAS NOT BEEN A GOOD DAY TO
SIT BY THE TELE.
>> THE LATEST TRUMP COMMENTS
HAVE THEM SWARMING.
>> DO THEY SPELL TROUBLE FOR
TRUMP?
>> A MAJOR DECLINE, NOW TRAILING
HILLARY CLINTON BY DOUBLE
DIGITS.
THAT'S NOT THE WORST PART.
AN OVERWHELMING 55% OF THOSE
POLLED SAY THEY COULD NEVER VOTE
FOR DONALD TRUMP, AS WELL AS 63%
OF WOMEN SAY THEY COULD NEVER
SUPPORT HIM.
>> A POLL SHOWS DONALD TRUMP
WITH A 70% UNFAVORABLE RATING.
NOBODY HAS EVER GOT ELECTED
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES
WITH A 70% UNFAVORABLE RATING.
>> PEOPLE DON'T LIKE WHAT THEY
ARE HEARING AND HAVE STARTED TO
TURN AGAINST HIM.
>> THEN THERE IS THE LATEST
FIGHT WITH MEMBERS OF THE MEDIA.
>> DID THE WASHINGTON POST --
WITH A BAND, YES OR NO?
>> THE TREND IS WHAT HAS REALLY
GOT TO BE TROUBLING FOR DONALD
TRUMP.
ED HAS BEEN A MONTH OF
CONTROVERSY.
>> AFTER TRUMP'S COMMENTS, YOU
HAVE PAUL RYAN AND MITCH
MCCONNELL AGREEING WITH BARACK
OBAMA AND HILLARY CLINTON ABOUT
HIS COMMENTS.
>> WHAT DO YOU BELIEVE IS GOING
THROUGH PAUL RYAN'S MIND NOW?
MARK: THAT IS SOME BAD
INFORMATION FLOW FOR THE
REPUBLICAN.
DONALD TRUMP IS SOMEWHAT OF A
MAN ALONE ON AN ISLAND.
HE MADE IT CLEAR THAT BEING
ALONE ON THAT ISLAND IS OK WITH
HIM AT A RALLY TODAY.
>> THE REPUBLICANS, HONESTLY,
FOLKS, OUR LEADERS HAVE TO GET
TOUGHER.
THIS IS TOO TOUGH TO DO IT
ALONE.
BUT YOU KNOW WHAT, I THINK I
WILL BE FORCED TO.
I THINK I WILL BE FORCED TO.
OUR LEADERS HAVE TO GET A LOT
TOUGHER, AND BE QUIET, PLEASE,
BE QUIET, DON'T TALK, JUST BE
QUIET.
THEY HAVE TO GET TOUGHER,
SHARPER.
WE HAVE TO HAVE REPUBLICANS DID
TOGETHER OR LET ME JUST DO IT BY
MYSELF.
I WILL DO VERY WELL, I WILL DO
VERY WELL, OK?
MARK: BASED ON OUR POLL AND
DONALD TRUMP'S ATTITUDE, HOW BIG
ARE HIS TROUBLES?
JOHN: THEY ARE PRETTY BIG.
I THINK THAT REACTION TODAY IS
MAYBE THE DEEPEST TROUBLE OF
ALL.
YOU AND I HEAR FROM PEOPLE EVERY
DAY ON TWITTER AND OTHER PLACES,
WHO CASTED DISPERSIONS ON TRUMP
AND SAY HE SUFFERS FROM
NARCISSISTIC PERSONALITY
DISORDER.
THAT DISPLAY RIGHT THERE, THE
NOTION THAT YOU CAN GO IT ALONE
AND BECOME PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES OF THE NOMINEE OF
THE REPUBLICAN PARTY WITH NO
HELP FROM ANYBODY.
IT'S ALL ME.
IT'S ALL GOING TO BE ME.
IT IS NOT IN TOUCH WITH REALITY.
NOT BEING IN TOUCH WITH REALITY
MAKES IT HARD TO WIN A
PRESIDENTIAL RACE.
MARK: TRUMP PLAYS BY DIFFERENT
RULES, HE HAS LOST A LOT OF NEWS
CYCLES AND A ROW WHEN HILLARY
CLINTON HAS TO DEAL WITH HER
E-MAIL PROBLEM, BAD JOB NUMBERS,
HE IS LOSING CYCLES.
REPUBLICANS ARE NOTICING.
PEOPLE WILL MAKE A SNAP JUDGMENT
THAT THE RACE IS OVER, BUT
THERE'S A LOT OF TIME LEFT.
WHERE HE IS NOW IS IN A BAD
PLACE, AND NOTHING HE HAS DONE
THIS WEEK SO FAR HAS TURNED
THINGS AROUND.
JOHN: LET'S BE CLEAR.
WE STARTED POLLING TRUMPS
NUMBERS A YEAR AGO, VERY BAD
NUMBERS, VERY BAD NUMBERS, AND
HE IMPROVED THEM.
THE IMPROVED THEM IN THE CONTEXT
OF A NOMINATION FIGHT WHERE
THERE WERE QUESTIONS ABOUT HIS
TEMPERAMENT AMONG VOTERS, BUT
NOT HIS BASIC POLICY STANCES.
NOW YOU ARE IN THIS GENERAL
ELECTION CONTEST, MUCH BIGGER
ELECTORATE, MANY AVAILABLE
VOTERS ARE NOT ON TRUMP'S SIDE.
THE THINGS HE HAS SAID AND DONE
HAVE, I THINK, THERE IS A GOOD
CASE TO MAKE, THAT THEY MAY HAVE
TURNED THOSE PEOPLE OFF POSSIBLY
PERMANENTLY.
MARK: IT WAS A BIG FIELD, BUT
OVERMATCHED.
NOW HE'S RUNNING AGAINST TWO
PEOPLE WHO CAN COMMAND THE STAGE
DOES AS MUCH AS HE CAN.
HE HAS A BIG PROBLEM.
JOHN: HE HAS A VERY BIG PROBLEM.
DONALD TRUMP'S DUBIOUS WEEK MATE
EVEN BE MORE DIRE THAN NATIONAL
POLL NUMBERS SUGGEST.
ALL EYES ARE ON THE REPUBLICAN
LEADERS WHO ARE TELLING TRUMP TO
BE QUIET TODAY, NOTABLY PAUL
RYAN AND MITCH MCCONNELL.
NEITHER OF THOSE LEADERS AS HE
DID DONALD ADVICE TO BE QUIET.
THEY ARE CRITICAL OF HIS
RHETORIC AND BOTH DODGE
QUESTIONS ABOUT HIM YESTERDAY,
MAKING IT CLEAR THEY WILL NOT
WEIGH IN ON THE PRESIDENTIAL
RACE EVERY TIME WHEN THE
PRESUMPTIVE REPUBLICAN NOMINEE
SAYS SOMETHING CONTROVERSIAL.
WE DECIDED TO CALL THE MAIN
SOURCES OF DONALD TRUMP'S
TRAVAILS, THE THREE D'S.
DATA, DONORS, THEN THE ONGOING
DISSENSION WITHIN DONALD TRUMP'S
CAMPAIGN.
LET'S START WITH THE FIRST D.
WHAT DATA BEYOND POLL NUMBERS,
WILL KIND OF PRIVATE PHONE
NUMBERS ARE SPOOKING
REPUBLICANS?
MARK: THERE WAS A TIME WHEN THEY
SAID DONALD TRUMP MAY WIN OR MAY
NOT, BUT WE WILL GET A LOT OF
DONATIONS AND WE WILL SUPPORT
OUR MAJORITIES.
NOW THEY ARE BEGINNING TO SEE
THAT TRUMPS NATIONAL NUMBERS ARE
STARTING TO AFFECT DOWN BALLOT
RACES.
THEY WILL PULL A LOT DURING THE
NEXT WEEK AND SEE HOW THIS IS
AFFECTING THINGS.
THE MINUTE THEY THINK THAT
DONALD WILL COST THEM THEIR
MAJORITY, THERE VIEW OF THE
WORLD WILL CHANGE DRAMATICALLY.
NOW THEY THINK IT COULD BECOME A
REALITY.
IF HE BECOMES A REALITY BEFORE
THE CONVENTION, I BELIEVE THAT
MITCH MCCONNELL AND PAUL RYAN
COULD MOVE TO DO THAT.
JOHN: CHANGE THE RULES.
IT HAS GONE IN WAVES, THE DONALD
TRUMP MOVEMENT AND WHAT YOU
WOULD HAVE TWO DO TO STOP HIM.
WHETHER IT CAN HAPPEN OR NOT, WE
DON'T KNOW, BUT THERE ARE A LOT
OF PEOPLE TALKING ABOUT IT.
THE TROUBLE FOR REPUBLICANS IS
THAT IF THEY EMBRACE DONALD
TRUMP, THEY ARE WORRIED ABOUT
GETTING DRAGGED DOWN.
IF THEY DISTANCED THEMSELVES,
THEY ARE STILL SEEING THEMSELVES
BEING DRAGGED DOWN.
THAT'S WHY IT LEADS A LOT OF
PEOPLE TO START THINKING WHAT
WOULD OTHERWISE BE UNTHINKABLE.
MARK: CAN THEY WIN IT DOWN
BALLOT VICTORY IF THEY LOSE
ESTATE?
THERE'S 25-30 SEATS MAX AT PLAY
IN THE HOUSE.
THEY WILL BRING SOME RACES INTO
PLAY THAT NO ONE IS THINK
ING ABOUT.
JOHN: EVERYBODY IS GOING DOWN.
MARK: SAY GOODBYE TO THE
MAJORITY.
THE SECOND D.
WHAT IS GOING ON WITH THE DONOR
CLASS?
JOHN: IT SEEMS TO ME THAT THERE
ARE TWO DIFFERENT CATEGORIES,
REPUBLICAN DONORS WHO GOT ON THE
DONALD TRUMP BANDWAGON
RELUCTANTLY UNDER ARE HAVING A
LOT OF SECOND THOUGHTS ABOUT IT
AND ARE NOT ENTHUSED AND
WORRIED.
THEN THERE ARE THOSE WHO WERE
SUFFICIENTLY CONCERNED BEFORE
AND DID NOT GET ON THE BANDWAGON
.
THOSE PEOPLE, NONE OF THEM HAVE
ANY PLANS TO JOIN UP WITH THE
DONALD TRUMP FORCES IN THE
FORESEEABLE FUTURE.
MARK: SOME OF THE DONORS HAVE
BEEN CHARMED BY DONALD TRUMP,
THEY LIKE HIM AND ARE NOT TRYING
TO STAND UP TO HIM.
THERE ARE A GROUP OF PEOPLE WHO
WERE HOPING TO USE THE LEVERAGE
OF DONORS, BUT DONALD TRUMP GAVE
A SPEECH LAST TUESDAY THAT THE
DONORS WOULD BE HAPPY WITH.
THEY ARE FREAKED OUT BY HIS LACK
OF DISCIPLINE AND THE INABILITY
OF OTHERS TO HAVE INFLUENCE OVER
HIS BEHAVIOR.
THE DONOR CLASS WILL NOT GIVE TO
DOWN BALLOT RACES IF THEY THINK
IT IS A LOST CAUSE, SO THEY ARE
CURRENTLY FEELING AS NEGATIVE
ABOUT TRUMP AS A GROUP OVER AS
ANYBODY IN THE PARTY.
JOHN: THAT JUST FEEDS BACK INTO
THE THING WE TALKED ABOUT AT THE
BEGINNING.
IN A SITUATION WHERE DONORS
THINK THAT DONALD TRUMP WILL
LOSE, BUT SURVIVABLE IN THE
HOUSE AND SENATE, THEY WILL TAKE
ALL THE MONEY AND GIVE IT TO
THESE DOWN BALLOT RACES.
IF THEY SEE THIS IS THE TITANIC
OR LUSITANIA, THEY WOULD JUST
SIT THERE ON THEIR WALLETS, AND
THAT BECOMES PART OF A NEGATIVE
CYCLE THAT MAKES LOSING THE
HOUSE AND SENATE MORE LIKELY.
MARK: ASSUMING HE MAKES NO
ADDITIONAL MISTAKES, I THINK
HE WAS SEE REPUBLICAN DONORS
RAISING MONEY FOR HILLARY
CLINTON.
JOHN: THE THIRD D, DISSENSION.
WE HAVE HAD A LOT OF REPORTS.
MARK: IT'S A BIG PROBLEM.
ALL CAMPAIGNS GOT THE ROUGH
SPOTS.
SMART CAMPAIGNS REACH OUT.
HE SELL WHEN THE CLINTON
CAMPAIGN WAS HAVING TROUBLE.
-- YOU SAW WHEN THE CLINTON
PUT ON SOME DIAPERS, PUT SOME
PLASTIC SHEETING ON THE BED IF
THEY WET THE BED.
THE TRUNK CAMPAIGN IS IN
CONFUSION IN DISARRAY RIGHT NOW.
THAT DISARRAY IS FREAKING PEOPLE
OUT BECAUSE WHEN A CAMPAIGN IS
GOING TO TURBULENCE, YOU WANT TO
SEE STABILITY, COHESIVENESS.
PEOPLE AREN'T SENSING THAT AND
IT IS FRUSTRATING THEM.
JOHN: THE TWO MOST INFLUENTIAL
PEOPLE IN DONALD TRUMP'S WORLD,
IF YOU TALK TO THEIR FRIENDS,
NONE OF THEM WILL SAY TO YOU,
LOOK YOU IN YOUR EYE AND SAY, MY
GUY IS RUNNING THE SHOW.
NONE OF THEM.
NO ONE KNOWS.
NO MATTER WHO YOU SIDE WITH, NO
ONE KNOWS WHO IS RUNNING THE
CAMPAIGN AT THIS POINT.
MOST OF THEM WON'T EVEN SAY
THERE REALLY IS A CAMPAIGN.
MARK: IF THE DONALD TRUMP
CAMPAIGN COULD REASSURED MITCH
MCCONNELL AND PAUL RYAN THAT WE
WILL PICK A GREAT RUNNING MAY
COME HAVE A GREAT CONVENTION,
THAT WOULD SETTLE PEOPLE DOWN,
BUT THE CONFUSION FROM THE
CAMPAIGN IS NOT GIVING PEOPLE
CONFIDENCE THAT THEY WILL HIT
THOSE MARKS ON THOSE BIG
MOMENTS.
JOHN: THEY COULD NOT STOP HIM
FROM DOING SOME OF THE DAMAGE,
AND WHO COULD STOP HIM?
MARK: DEMOCRATS GEARING UP FOR
ANOTHER BIG FIGHT OVER GUN
CONTROL.
WE WILL TALK MORE ABOUT WHAT
HAPPENED IN THE SENATE TODAY
WITH A FILIBUSTER AFTER THIS
QUICK WORD FROM OUR SPONSORS.
♪
MARK: AFTER THE ORLANDO
SHOOTING, TALK TURNED TO THE
POTENTIAL EFFECTS THE ATTACK
COULD HAVE ON THE WAR ON TERROR,
LGBT WRITES, AND GUN CONTROL.
-- LGBT RIGHTS, AND GUN CONTROL.
TODAY, DONALD TRUMP TWEETED "I
WILL BE MEETING WITH THE NRA,
WHO HAS ENDORSED ME, THAT NOT
ALLOWING PEOPLE ON THE NO-FLY
LIST TO BUY GUNS."
SENATE DEMOCRATS LED BY CHRIS
MURPHY SPENT THE AFTERNOON
FILIBUSTERING A SPENDING BILL
AND AN ATTEMPT TO ADD IN A MEMO
THAT WOULD CLOSE THE GUN SHOW
LOOPHOLE AND PREVENT PEOPLE ON
THE NO-FLY LIST FROM BUYING
GUNS.
HERE IS MURPHY TALKING ABOUT THE
NEW TOWN ELEMENTARY SCHOOL
SHOOTING.
>> AS SOMEONE WHO REPRESENTS THE
COMMUNITY OF SANDY HOOK, WHICH
IS STILL GRIEVING TODAY, I WILL
STAND ON THIS FLOOR AND TALK
ABOUT OUR EXPERIENCE IN SANDY
HOOK, ORLANDO'S EXPERIENCE, THE
NEED TO COME TOGETHER ON THIS
ISSUE OF MAKING SURE THAT
DANGEROUS PEOPLE WHO HAVE
DESIGNS ON MASS MURDER DON'T GET
DANGEROUS WEAPONS AS LONG AS I
CAN SO THAT WE CAN GIVE TIME TO
TRY TO FIGURE OUT A PATH
FORWARD.
JOHN: VICE PRESIDENT BIDEN IS
EXPECTED TO DELIVER A SPEECH IN
SANDY HOOK TONIGHT.
MY QUESTION AS WE TAKE THIS ALL
AND IS WHETHER THIS IS JUST
ANOTHER TEMPORARY SKIRMISH IN
THE GUN-CONTROL BATTLE OR
POTENTIALLY A LEADING INDICATOR
OF MEANINGFUL CHANGE WHEN IT
COMES TO GUN RIGHTS.
MARK: I THINK IT IS A PRETTY BIG
MOMENT.
I DON'T WANT OVER IT.
-- DON'T WANT TO OVERSTATE IT.
YOU NOW HAVE DEMOCRATS IN
CONGRESS BEING PRETTY
AGGRESSIVE.
I'M NOT SURE WHAT THE DONALD
TRUMP TWEET MEANS ENTIRELY, BUT
IT DOES SUGGEST THAT IF HILLARY
CLINTON WINS THE WHITE HOUSE,
DEMOCRATS TAKE THE SENATE, AND
THEY EAT INTO THE HOUSE, EVERY
CLINTON COULD CLAIM A MANDATE.
THAT WOULD BE DIFFERENT THAN HER
DEMOCRATIC PREDECESSOR, TO START
THE ADMINISTRATION THAT WAY.
JOHN: SOME THINGS COULD FALL
INTO PLACE THAT WOULD CHANGE THE
CALCULUS.
IT'S ALSO THE CASE THAT MITCH
MCCONNELL CAME OUT YESTERDAY AND
MADE SOME COMMENTS, I'VE NEVER
HEARD MCCONNELL SAYING THAT HE
WOULD BE OPEN TO CONSIDERING
GUN-CONTROL CHANGE.
IT IS A LOW PROBABILITY, BUT NOT
IMPOSSIBLE, THAT A COUPLE OF
THESE ISSUES, PARTICULARLY
NO-FLY, WE COULD GET ACTUAL
LEGISLATION PASSED ON THIS IN
THE NEXT FEW WEEKS.
IT IS POSSIBLE.
MARK: I THINK YOU CAN GET IT
THROUGH THE SENATE, BUT NOT THE
HOUSE.
GETTING IT THROUGH THE SENATE
WOULD BE A BIG WIN.
I DON'T THINK ANYTHING WILL PASS
UNTIL NEXT YEAR, BUT I THINK
THERE IS A CHANCE THAT DEMOCRATS
WILL PUSH THIS FOR MOMENTUM.
JOHN: I THINK YOU WILL SEE
HILLARY CLINTON LEADING THE
CHARGE.
THIS IS A DIFFERENT ISSUE THAN
IT HAS BEEN FOR 20 YEARS NOW.
MARK: EVEN DONALD TRUMP'S ALLIES
HAVE NOW ADMITTED THAT THE
PRESUMPTIVE GOP NOMINEE HAS HAD
A NOT SO STELLAR MONTH.
HILLARY CLINTON'S CAMPAIGN COULD
CHOOSE TO SIT BACK AND WAIT AND
WATCH WHILE THEIR OPPONENTS
SELF-DESTRUCTS.
INSTEAD, CLINTON HAS BEEN PRETTY
AGGRESSIVE.
SHE HAS KEPT THE PRESSURE ON HER
REPUBLICAN ARRIVAL.
SHE DID IT AGAIN TODAY WHILE
TALKING ABOUT NATIONAL SECURITY
AND VIRGINIA.
>> SO NOT ONE OF DONALD TRUMP'S
RECKLESS IDEAS WOULD HAVE SAVED
A SINGLE LIFE IN ORLANDO.
IT IS JUST MORE EVIDENCE THAT HE
IS TEMPERAMENTALLY UNFIT AND
TOTALLY UNQUALIFIED TO BE
COMMANDER-IN-CHIEF.
MARK: SO CLINTON SAID IN AN
INTERVIEW IN WHICH SHE TALKED
ABOUT A SPEECH YOU WILL GIVE,
STAYING ON TRUMP, SAYING HE IS
UNFIT.
WHAT CAN SHE DO TO TAKE
ADVANTAGE AGGRESSIVELY OF DONALD
TRUMP'S CURRENT PROBLEMS?
JOHN: YOU SAW IT YESTERDAY.
IF I WAS A DEMOCRATIC MASTER
STRATEGIST, I WOULD HAVE HILLARY
CLINTON AND BARACK OBAMA ON A
SERIES OF ISSUES HAMMERING
TRUMP, DOING IT IN TANDEM, AND
GOING AFTER EVERY POLICY ISSUE,
TURNING IT INTO A CHARACTER
ISSUE.
IF DONALD TRUMP REACTS, HE WILL
GIVE THEM PLENTY OF FODDER.
MARK: ONE IS THAT HER
PERFORMANCE CONTINUES TO BE MUCH
BETTER THAN IT WAS, NO MORE
SHOUTING, CONFIDENT
DISCUSSION OF TRUMP.
THE SECOND IS FOCUSING ON DATA,
HAVING HER CAMPAIGN READY TO
BUILD OPERATIONS THE DONALD
TRUMP CAN'T MATCH.
FINALLY, REPUBLICANS, SUPPORTING
REPUBLICANS NOW THAT SANDERS IS
EASING OUT OF THE HOW TO TIME
THE ANNOUNCEMENT OF SUPPORT --
IS EASING OUT OF THE RACE.
HOW TO TIME THE ANNOUNCEMENT OF
SUPPORT.
THIS WILL GET A TON OF
ATTENTION.
JOHN: THERE HAS BEEN A MONTH OF
ADVERTISING IN BATTLEGROUND
STATES ALMOST UNANSWERED BY
DONALD TRUMP.
WHILE DONALD TRUMP HAS BEEN
TAKING A LONG TURN IN THE
BARREL, IT'S HARD TO IMAGINE THE
FIVE MONTHS BETWEEN NOW AND
NOVEMBER WILL GO WITHOUT HILLARY
CLINTON HAVING A FEW BAD WEEKS
OF HER OWN.
HER NEGATIVES ARE STILL PRETTY
HIGH.
54% OF VOTERS IN OUR BLOOMBERG
POLITICS POLL HAVE AN
UNFAVORABLE VIEW OF THE
PRESUMPTIVE DEMOCRATIC NOMINEE,
WHILE 50 5% SAID THE SAME THING
IN THE ABC NEWS WASHINGTON POST
SURVEY.
KNOWING WHAT WE KNOW, LET'S FLIP
THIS COIN AROUND.
WHAT ARE THE THINGS THAT COULD
HAPPEN THAT WOULD SEND HILLARY
CLINTON INTO THE BARREL?
MARK: THE BIGGEST THREAT TO HER
IS THE PRESS FAVORING TRUMP.
I THOUGHT AND A GENERAL ELECTION
THAT MIGHT BE A BIG ADVANTAGE.
BANNING THE WASHINGTON POST FROM
HIS EVENTS AND BEHAVING THE WAY
HE HAS ON A VARIETY OF ISSUES
THAT OFFEND SENSIBILITIES,
CHANCES ARE LOWER THAT HER
WINNING STREAK WILL END ANYTIME
SOON.
HER E-MAILS ARE A POTENTIAL
THING TO PUT HER IN THE BARREL.
ANOTHER COULD BE A SCANDAL
INVOLVING THE CLINTONS ARE
CLINTON FOUNDATION.
THEN A GAFFE OF HUGE PROPORTIONS
--
JOHN: SHE HAS NOT BEEN GAFFE IN
MUCH LATELY.
MARK: I'M SURE IT WILL HAPPEN,
BUT I'M NOT SURE IT WILL HAPPEN
BEFORE THE CONVENTION.
THEY HAVE BEEN CAREFUL AND
AGGRESSIVE.
JOHN: THE E-MAIL THING, I CAN'T
HELP BUT FIND SOME SYMPATHY OR
SENSE OF AGREEMENT WITH THOSE
WHO YESTERDAY SEEING THE DATA
BREACH REVEALED THAT RUSSIAN
HACKERS HAD GOTTEN INTO THE DNC
COMPUTER SYSTEM AS RAISING A
HUGE RED FLAG AROUND HILLARY
CLINTON'S E-MAIL.
THE FACT THAT THE DNC'S COMPUTER
WAS BREACHED RAISES THE QUESTION
OF WHETHER HER'S WAS BREACHED.
IF THAT WERE TRUE AND SOMETHING
WAS COMPROMISE, SHE WOULD BE
BACK IN THE BARREL AGAIN.
MARK: UP NEXT, A HILLARY CLINTON
SUPPORTER AND AN AD PERSON WALK
INTO HIS STUDIO.
THAT IS NOT A JOKE.
♪
MARK: JOINING US NOW IS THE
FORMER DEMOCRATIC CONGRESSMAN
FROM TENNESSEE AND HILLARY
CLINTON SUPPORTER --
AND THE STRATEGIST, BRAD
DAVIS.
>> IT HASN'T BEEN HIS BEST WEEK
OR BEST COUPLE OF WEEKS.
I THINK WE WOULD ALL AGREE ON
THAT.
WHAT IS BEING OVERSTATED IS THAT
THIS WILL LAST FOREVER.
I THINK THEY WILL GET THEIR ACT
TOGETHER.
THEY WILL EVENTUALLY WORK
TOGETHER FINE.
I THINK HE WILL BE THE NOMINEE
AND WILL COME OUT OF THE
CONVENTION MUCH STRONGER THAN
YOU SEE RIGHT NOW.
MARK: IF HILLARY CLINTON SAID TO
YOU, WHAT SHOULD I BE WORRIED
ABOUT?
WHAT SHOULD SHE SEE BEWARE IT
BE WORRIED ABOUT?
>> SHE HAS DONE TWO THINGS, NOT
ALLOW DONALD TRUMP TO DOMINATE
EVERY NEW CYCLE.
SHE IS GETTING HER MESSAGE OUT.
SHE WAS ABLE TO ENGAGE PRESIDENT
OBAMA VERY EARLY.
SHE GOT THE PRESIDENT IN
MIDSEASON FORM IN JUNE WORRIED I
DID NOT EXPECT TO SEE HIM AT
THIS LEVEL OF INVOLVEMENT AND
THIS AGGRESSIVE LEVEL
INVOLVEMENT UNTIL --
MARK: IS THERE ANYTHING SHE
SHOULD BE WORRIED ABOUT NOW?
>> I THINK THIS WILL BE A LONG
RACE.
THIS IS NOT A DECISIVE WEEK.
IT HAS BEEN A GOOD WEEK, BUT AS
DONALD TRUMP IS PROVEN, HE IS
RESILIENT.
WE CONTINUE TO READ DATA WHERE
HIS SUPPORTERS CONTINUE TO STAND
WITH HIM.
IT IS EARLY.
SHE HAS THE ADVANTAGE, BUT THIS
IS GOING TO BE A LONG RACE.
FOR ANYONE IN THE CLINTON
CAMPAIGN TO BELIEVE THAT THIS
ONE WEEK WILL DECIDED, IT IS
MISGUIDED.
MARK: STAY WITH US.
WE WILL COME BACK FOR MORE FROM
OUR BLOOMBERG POLITICS NATIONAL
POLL, WHERE WE ASK LIKELY VOTERS
WHO THEY THINK THE NOMINEE
SHOULD TAKE AS THEIR RUNNING
MATES.
WE WILL TALK ABOUT THOSE NAMES
AND MORE DEEP INSIDE THE DATA ON
TRUMP AND CLINTON RIGHT AFTER
THIS.
♪
.
JOHN: WE ARE BACK WITH
REPUBLICAN MEDIA CONSULTANT AND
FORMER TENNESSEE CONGRESSMAN AND
MARGINALLY LESS HANDSOME MAN,
HAROLD FORD.
I WANT TO ASK FRED -- WE DID
THIS BLOOMBERG POLITICS
NATIONAL: ONE OF THE THINGS WE
ASKED WAS THROUGH THEIR PICKS
WERE FOR THEIR PARTY NOMINEES.
THE LIST OF POTENTIAL RUNNING
MATE, WANT TO GIVE YOU THE TOP
FOUR.
NEWT GINGRICH AT 29%, OUR GURU
VIA, 24%, JOHN KASICH AT 18% AND
CHRIS CHRISTIE AT 9%.
WHAT DO YOU THINK OF THE IDEA OF
NEWT GINGRICH AS DONALD TRUMP'S
RUNNING MATE?
FRED: I THINK HIS STRENGTH IS AS
THE CHAIRMAN OF THE BOARD, THE
GUY WHO GETS TO USE THE BULLY
PULPIT ALL OVER AMERICA.
HE NEEDS SOMEONE WHO IS AN
OPERATING OFFICER OF THAT LIST.
I WOULD PUT KASICH AT THE TOP OF
THE LIST AS SOMEONE WHO HAS
PROVEN HE CAN GET THINGS DONE
WHILE DONALD IS OUT BEING
DONALD.
JOHN: DO YOU THINK HE WOULD PICK
THE GIG IF YOU ARE OFFERED IT?
FRED: I DON'T THINK HE WOULD.
HE MADE HIS HE'S WITH HIS RUN
FOR PRESIDENCY AND IS HAPPY TO
BE BACK IN OHIO.
MARK: DEMOCRATS WOULD BE
COMPLETELY AFRAID OF NEWT
GINGRICH GOT ON THE TICKET.
I THINK THERE WOULD BE SIX OR
SEVEN MARRIAGES ON THAT TICKET.
HAROLD: I SERVED WITH HIM.
I THINK HE IS A SMART GUY BUT I
THINK FRED IS RIGHT ABOUT THE
KIND OF NEED DONALD TRUMP HAS
AND IT IS UNCLEAR OF NEWT
GINGRICH WOULD FIT THAT ROLE.
MARK: WE ASKED ABOUT POTENTIAL
RUNNING MATES FOR HILLARY
CLINTON.
ELIZABETH WAR AND WAS THE TOP
CHOICE.
CORY BOOKER, 17%.
NOT SURE, 15% AND JULIAN CASTRO,
12%.
ELIZABETH MORAN -- I BELIEVE
THERE IS NO CHANCE HILLARY
CLINTON WOULD PICK HER, BUT
THAT'S THE TEST READY POPULAR
SUPPORT.
HAROLD: MRS. CLINTON HAS
INDICATED SHE WOULD KEEP AN OPEN
MIND.
SHE CLEARLY EARLY ON, THE MOST
EFFECTIVE CRITIQUE OF DONALD
TRUMP, FOLLOWED WITH AN EQUALLY
IMPRESSIVE ONE.
I KNOW CORY BOOKER.
HE COULD CERTAINLY HELP
RELATIONS IN THE CONGRESS.
I DON'T KNOW SECRETARY CASTRO,
BUT I DO KNOW TIM KAINE AND
SHERROD BROWN, I THINK WOULD
BRING A LOT OF THINGS TO THE
TICKET AND WOULD HELP CLINTON
SURE UP SOME CONSTITUENCY
SUPPORT.
JOHN: I'M GOING TO ASK YOU TO DO
SOMETHING THAT IS NOT GOING TO
MAKE YOU COMFORTABLE.
WHO DO YOU THINK WOULD BE THE
BEST VICE PRESIDENTIAL PICK FOR
HILLARY CLINTON?
WHO WOULD BE THE BEST?
HAROLD: ALL OF THOSE WOULD BE
GOOD.
BUT WHO HELPED HER WIN AND WHO
HELPS HER WITH CONSTITUENCIES WE
NEED THE MOST HELP WITH?
I THINK TIM KAINE -- I THINK
THOSE THREE GUYS BRING A LOT TO
THE TABLE.
MARK: 32% SAID THEY HAD A
FAVORABLE VIEW OF THE REPUBLICAN
BRAND.
IS DONALD TRUMP HELPING OR
HURTING THE REPUBLICAN BRAND
RIGHT NOW?
FRED: I THINK HE'S CHANGING THE
REPUBLICAN BRAND.
IT'S PROBABLY HURTING THIS WEEK.
IN THE LONG RUN, I AM OF THE
FEELING HE'S BRINGING NEW PEOPLE
AND NEW EXCITEMENT TO THE
REPUBLICAN PARTY.
IT IS A PARTY THAT HAS BEEN A
LITTLE CONFUSED THROUGH THE
PRIMARY PROCESS AND I THINK
THERE'S A CLARITY.
WHETHER THE ESTABLISHMENT LIKES
THE CLARITY, WE WILL SEE HOW
THAT TURNS OUT THAT IT IS A
POSSIBLE POSITIVE.
JOHN: WE PLAYED EARLIER IN THE
SHOW DONALD TRUMP SAYING TODAY I
MAY HAVE TO GO IT ALONE HERE.
IF I HAVE TO DO THIS ON MY OWN,
I WILL DO IT ON MY OWN.
LET ME GET ON WITH THE BUSINESS
OF RUNNING FOR PRESIDENT, I CAN
DO IT ON MY OWN.
IS THAT A SENSIBLE STRATEGY OR
WAY OF LOOKING AT THE WORLD WHEN
YOU ARE A MAJOR PARTY NOMINEE?
FRED: IT PROBABLY WOULD NOT HAVE
BEEN MY ADVICE TO HIM.
BUT YOU KNOW WHAT IT IS LIKE IN
THAT SEAT.
WITH PAUL RYAN AND MITCH
MCCONNELL AND PEOPLE WHO ARE
VERY SHARP, GOOD, ESTABLISHMENT
ALL EDITIONS NIPPING AT YOUR
HEELS, WHAT ARE YOU GOING TO DO?
DONALD TRUMP IS NOT THE KIND TO
SIT BACK AND LET ME FALL IN
LINE.
THAT'S NOT WHY PEOPLE LIKE HIM.
HE'S OUT THERE FIGHTING FOR HIS
EVERY BREATH AND I THINK YOU
WILL DO THAT AND I THINK THAT'S
PART OF HIS UNUSUAL POPULARITY.
MARK: IF YOU WERE SITTING IN THE
SENATE COMMITTEE AND THEY SAID
IF DONALD TRUMP IS AT THE TOP OF
THE TICKET, YOU WILL LOSE THE
TOP OF THE MAJORITY.
WHAT WOULD YOU ADVISE HE DO?
CREDIT: I WOULD SAY WE NEED TO
CHANGE THAT DYNAMIC AND GET ON
BOARD.
I AGREE WITH HAROLD.
HILLARY AND OBAMA HAVE MADE A
GREAT TAG TEAM THIS WEEK.
NOBODY IS OVERLY ELATED IN
AMERICA ABOUT DONALD TRUMP OR
HILLARY CLINTON.
THEIR NEGATIVES ARE TOO HIGH.
BUT THE DEMOCRATS HAVE DONE A
FAR BETTER JOB OF COALESCING
BEHIND HER AND MOVING FORWARD.
I THINK IT'S ABOUT TIME FOR
REPUBLICANS TO DO THE SAME
THING.
I WILL PROBABLY GET A THOUSAND
UNCLES WERE THAT THAT THAT WOULD
BE MY ADVICE.
MARK: IN AN INTERVIEW, SECRETARY
CLINTON REFUSED TO COMMIT TO
KEEPING DEBBIE WASSERMAN SCHULTZ
AS THE CHAIR AFTER SHE BECOMES
THE OFFICIAL NOMINEE.
WHAT ARE THE POLITICS OF THAT
ANSWER?
HAROLD: I'VE SAID REPEATEDLY I
THINK THE CHAIRWOMAN MADE THINGS
MESSIER THAN IT SHOULD HAVE
BEEN.
SHE HAD EVERY RIGHT TO PROFESS
HER SUPPORT FOR MRS. CLINTON BUT
I THINK THERE IS SOME CREDENCE
TO WHAT BERNIE SANDERS WAS
SAYING.
IF WE REACH A POINT WHERE THE
ONLY WAY WE ARE ABLE TO KEEP
HARMONY AT THE CONVENTION IS FOR
DEBBIE WASSERMAN SCHULTZ NOT TO
BE THE CHAIRWOMAN AND FOR
SOMEONE ELSE TO RUN THE
CONVENTION, ELECTING HILLARY
CLINTON IS THE MOST IMPORTANT
THING THEY SHOULD BE FOCUSED ON.
I DON'T HAVE ANY ISSUES WITH
WHAT MRS. CLINTON IS SAYING.
JOHN: I'M GOING TO ASK YOU TO
PUT IN LIKE YOU ARE THE CHIEF
ADVISERS TO BERNIE SANDERS RIGHT
NOW.
WHAT WOULD YOU TELL HIM TO DO?
HAROLD: TO BEGIN TO DRAFT A
SPEECH AND TALK ABOUT INCOME
INEQUALITY AND HOW YOU HAVE HAD
YOUR BATTLE WITH MRS. CLINTON
AND MRS. CLINTON WON FAIRLY AND
YOU LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
HER.
I WOULD CITE TWO OR THREE
INSTANCES WHERE YOU WORKED WITH
HER IN THE SENTENCE -- IN THE
SENATE AND LET'S MOVE FORWARD
AND MAKE CLEAR WE ARE HEADING TO
THIS CONVENTION UNIFIED.
IT APPEARS THERE WILL CONTINUE
TO BE FISHERS WITH THE
REPUBLICANS.
WE NEED TO LEAVE IT EVEN
STRONGER.
JOHN: FRED DAVIS, GREAT MAN,
HAROLD FORD, ADEQUATE MAN.
YOU ARE BOTH FANTASTIC.
LOVE HAVING YOU ON THE SHOW.
COMING UP, WE'LL HAVE MORE FROM
OUR BLOOMBERG POLITICS NATIONAL
POLL.
IF YOU ARE WATCHING IN
WASHINGTON DC, YOU CAN LISTEN TO
US ON THE RADIO RADIO.
WE WILL BE RIGHT BACK.
♪
MARK: JOINING US TO TALK MORE
ABOUT OUR BLOOMBERG TOP POLITICS
NATIONAL POLL AS OUR COLLEAGUE,
JOHN MCCORMICK WHO HAS DUG
THROUGH THE NUMBERS.
YOU CAN READ HIS STORIES ON
BLOOMBERG POLITICS.COM.
HE IS IN OUR CHICAGO EURO.
TALK ABOUT THIS ISSUE OF BRAND
WE ASKED FRED DAVIS ABOUT.
IT OBVIOUSLY CREATES THE
ENVIRONMENT OF THIS ELECTION.
GUEST: I THINK THIS POLL OFFERS
SOME EVIDENCE THAT DONALD TRUMP
IS NOT DOING ANYTHING POSITIVE
FOR THE REPUBLICAN BRAND RIGHT
NOW.
AS WE HAVE DISCUSSED, ONLY ABOUT
ONE THIRD OF AMERICANS VIEW THE
REPUBLICAN BRAND IN A FAVORABLE
WAY AND THAT'S THE LOWEST LEVEL
WE HAVE RECORDED IN A BLOOMBERG
POLL SINCE THE POLLS INCEPTION
IN 2009.
MARK: HOW IS THE DEMOCRATIC RAND
DOING?
GUEST: MUCH BETTER.
NOT GREAT, BUT ABOUT HALF OF
AMERICANS VIEW THE DEMOCRATIC
PARTY IN A FAVORABLE LIGHT.
THAT SETS UP THE CONTOURS FOR
THIS RACE THOSE AT THE
PRESIDENTIAL LEVEL AND
CONGRESSIONAL RACES AND DOWN
BALLOT RACES ETC..
JOHN: I'M STRUCK BY A THE NUMBER
IN THIS POLL -- 68% SAY THE
COUNTRY IS ON THE WRONG TRACK.
IT DIDN'T STOP BARACK OBAMA FROM
GETTING REELECTED IN 2012, BUT
IT IS A STRANGE THING TO ME THAT
THEY ARE THAT HIGH AND BARACK
OBAMA'S RATING IS WELL OVER 50%.
HOW DO WE RECONCILE THOSE
REALITIES?
GUEST: IT IS A START CONTRAST
AND SEEMS LIKE AN ENVIRONMENT
DONALD TRUMP COULD TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF, THAT SILLY
AMERICANS THINK AMERICA IS
HEADED IN THE WRONG DIRECTION.
THAT IS THE HIGHEST NUMBER WE'VE
RECORDED GOING BACK TO 2010 AND
2009.
IT IS AN ATMOSPHERE WHERE A
CHALLENGER TO THE INCUMBENT
PARTY WOULD HAVE AN ADVANTAGE.
WE'VE ALSO ASKED PEOPLE ABOUT
THEIR ECONOMIC AND PERSONAL
SITUATION IN LIFE.
A MAJORITY OF AMERICANS SAY THEY
ARE BETTER OFF AND WOULD FEEL
BETTER OFF THAN THEY DID AT THE
PEAK OF THE RECESSION IN EARLY
2009.
PEOPLE ARE FEELING BETTER ABOUT
THE SITUATION AND THERE'S A
WIDELY HELD BELIEF THAT THE
COUNTRY IS HEADED IN THE WRONG
DIRECTION.
MARK: THE BULK OF THIS POLL WAS
DONE BEFORE THE ORLANDO MASSACRE
, BUT SOME OF IT WAS DONE AFTER.
WHAT WERE THE TOP ISSUES FOR
VOTERS IN OUR SURVEY?
GUEST: JOBS AND THE ECONOMY ARE
ALMOST ALWAYS THE TOP ISSUE
PEOPLE LIST WHEN WE GIVE THEM A
CHOICE TO PICK FROM.
THAT WAS ABOUT A FIFTH OF THE
ELECTORATE, AMERICANS SAID JOBS
IN THE ECONOMY WERE THE TOP
ISSUE.
THE YOU COMBINE TERRORISM AND
ISIS, THE NUMBER APPROACHES AND
SURPASSES JOBS AND THE ECONOMY.
WE DID SEE A TICK UP IN THOSE
NUMBERS FOLLOWING THE TERRORIST
ATTACK IN THOSE -- IN ORLANDO.
WE WILL SEE HOW IT PLAYS OUT
OVER THE COMING WEEKS BUT
INITIALLY, PEOPLE ARE AT A
HEIGHTENED LEVEL OF CONCERN WHEN
IT COMES TO TERRORISM, AS WOULD
BE EXPECTED.
JOHN: WE JUST TALKED WITH HAROLD
DAVIS AND -- WITH FRED DAVIS AND
HAROLD FORD.
IF I LOOK AT THE NUMBERS,
POTENTIAL RUNNING MATES WERE
TRUMP AND CLINTON, THE FACT THAT
15% OF DEMOCRATIC VOTERS SAY
THEY ARE NOT SURE WHO HILLARY
CLINTON'S RUNNING MATE SHOULD BE
IS SORT OF STRIKING GIVEN THAT
IT SUGGESTS THERE'S A LITTLE
THIN THIS ON THE DEMOCRATIC
BENCH WHEN SHE SERVES TO CAST
ABOUT AND THINK ABOUT WHO SHE
SHOULD PUT ON THE TICKET.
TALK ABOUT THAT A LITTLE BIT.
GUEST: ABOUT ONE THIRD OF THE
PEOPLE THINK THAT SHE SHOULD
PICK ELIZABETH MORAN, BUT ONE
PERSON WE DID NOT ASK ABOUT WAS
BERNIE SANDERS.
WHILE IT SEEMS HIGHLY UNLIKELY
THAT SHE WOULD PICK SANDERS AS
HER RUNNING MATE, IF WE HAD HIM
ON THE LIST, I'M SURE HE WOULD
HAVE GOTTEN A LARGE SHARE OF THE
VOTE AS WELL.
NOT THAT ANY OF US KNOW VERY
WELL HOW THIS WILL PLAY OUT.
REALLY ONLY THE TWO PRESIDENTIAL
CANDIDATES HAVE A GOOD FIELD WHO
THEY WILL BE PICKING.
MARK: WE'VE ASKED ABOUT THE
CLINTON CONTROVERSIES AND WHICH
ONES BOTHER THE VOTERS.
I THINK ABOUT THIS IS GOOD NEWS
-- 50% SAY THEY WERE BOTHERED BY
THE HER WALL STREET SPEECHES.
45% SAY E-MAIL SERVER.
YOU HAVE TO ASSUME A LOT OF
THOSE ARE REPUBLICANS AND ABOUT
HALF THE COUNTRY OR LESS -- IT
SEEMS TO ME THOSE NUMBERS COULD
BE A LOT HIGHER AND BASICALLY I
THINK IT'S GOOD NEWS.
WHAT DO YOU THINK?
GUEST: I WOULD BE INCLINED TO
AGREE.
ON THE E-MAIL ISSUE, THERE'S A
CERTAIN AMOUNT OF FATIGUE.
IT HAS BEEN TALKED ABOUT FOR SO
LONG THAT UNLESS ANOTHER MAJOR
DEVELOPMENT BREAKS IN THE STORY,
A LOT OF AMERICANS ARE SAYING IT
HAS BEEN DISCUSSED.
REPUBLICANS VIEW IT AS A HUGE
ISSUE AND SOME INDEPENDENTS
WILL, BUT IN THE BROAD
ELECTORATE, WHEN WE LOOK AT THE
ENTIRE SCOPE OF WHO'S GOING TO
VOTE IN THIS ELECTION, IT
DOESN'T SEEM TO BE A MASSIVE
ISSUE.
JOHN: GOOD TO SEE YOU.
YOU HAVE BEEN WITH SECRETARY
CLINTON FOR A WILD.
EVERYTHING ABOUT THIS SHOW, AND
NOT JUST THIS SHOW HAS BEEN ALL
BAD FOR DONALD TRUMP AND ALL
GOOD FOR HILLARY CLINTON.
HOW ARE PEOPLE AROUND HER
FEELING ABOUT THE STATE OF THE
RACE?
GUEST: I THINK THEY ARE FEELING
PRETTY GOOD.
THEY HAVE SEEN THE LAST COUPLE
OF WEEKS BORN OUT EXACTLY WHAT A
WERE SAYING WHEN THE TIDE WAS
SHOULD RING IN DONALD TRUMP'S
FAVOR, BACK WHEN HE SEEMED LIKE
A WINNER AND PEOPLE WERE TALKING
ABOUT HIS RUST BELT STRATEGY AND
THE WAYS HE IS GOING TO CHANGE
THE ELECTORATE.
THEY WERE ARGUING THE
FUNDAMENTALS ARE WITH US.
YOU WILL SEE THIS CHANGE ONCE
DEMOCRATS COMES HOME AND BERNIE
SANDERS GETS OUT OF THE RACE AND
ARE SEEING THAT CERTAIN HAPPEN.
PRIVATELY, CLINTON FEELS THE
EVENTS OF THE LAST WEEK HAVE
SERVED TO MITIGATE SOME OF HER
WEAKNESSES OR WHAT WERE
PERCEIVED AS POTENTIAL
WEAKNESSES, NAMELY, PRECAUTIONS.
THAT HAS BEEN PORTRAYED AS
CLINICAL CALCULATION IN A WAY
THIS ELECTION CYCLE HAS GONE.
ESPECIALLY FOR REPUBLICANS WHO
RAN AGAINST TRUMP, THAT DID NOT
SEEM TO WORK.
WITH THE WAY THINGS HAVE PLAYED
OUT AFTER ORLANDO, THEY FEEL
LIKE HER CAUTION IS TURNING INTO
A STRENGTH WHICH IS A BIG DEAL.
MARK: TALK ABOUT SECRETARY
CLINTON IN THIS ISSUE AND DEBBIE
WASSERMAN SCHULTZ, SHE BEING
CAUTIOUS OR IS THERE A
POSSIBILITY SHE WOULD CONSIDER
REMOVING HER?
GUEST: I GET THE SENSE THEY
DON'T WANT TO DO ANYTHING NOW TO
PUT A FOOT WRONG WITH BERNIE
SANDERS.
I THINK THEY ARE TRYING TO BE
CAREFUL AROUND THAT, BUT I WILL
SAY I WAS SURPRISED BY HOW FAR
SHE WENT IN SAYING SHE WANTS A
NEW PARTY.
SHE USED THE WORD NEW TO SAY HOW
SHE WANTS DEMOCRATS TO MOVE
FORWARD.
THAT SUGGESTS THEY COULD BE
SERIOUS ABOUT THIS AND AT THE
END OF THE DAY, THEY WANT BERNIE
SANDERS TO PULL BACK AND I DON'T
THINK IT'S OUT OF THE REALM OF
POSSIBILITY THAT THE B WASSERMAN
SCHULTZ BECOMES A CASUALTY OF
THAT.
MARK: UP NEXT, WE WILL TALK
ABOUT DONALD TRUMP'S WAR AGAINST
THE MEDIA AND HIS BLACK LISTING
OF THE "WASHINGTON POST" RIGHT
AFTER THIS.
♪
JOHN: OUR NEXT GUEST WROTE HIS
LATEST COLUMN ABOUT DONALD TRUMP
AND HE'S HOPING THIS WILL BE
ABLE TO GET HIM CREDENTIALS TO
TRUMP HALF CAMPAIGNS EVENT.
HE PUBLISHED A STORY THAT CAME
OUT YESTERDAY ON HIS ROLE AS THE
MEDIA PUNISHER IN CHIEF.
HE'S WITH US HERE.
TELL US ABOUT THESE ENCOUNTERS
YOU HAVE BEEN HAVING WITH DONALD
TRUMP.
JIM: I'VE BEEN COVERING
POLITICS, NOT AS LONG AS YOU
GENTLE IN, BUT HAVE FOR A LONG
TIME.
I'VE NEVER HAD A CONVERSATION
WHERE I CALL AND SAY WHAT'S THE
POLLSTER OR STRATEGY AND THEY
SAY NO, MR. TRUMP WILL CALL YOU
MOMENTARILY AND THERE HE IS ON
THE PHONE.
MARK: THIS IS A HARD THING FOR
THE PRESS, BUT THE "WASHINGTON
POST" IS ABSOLUTELY NOW PART OF
THE STORY.
DID YOU GET THE SENSE HE
APPRECIATES THE BALANCE OF
FREEDOM OF THE PRESS GOING ON
HERE OR IS HE -- DOES HE
UNAPOLOGETICALLY VIEW IT AS I
CAN JUST KICK ANYONE OUT OF
THESE EVENTS?
JIM: IT IS UNAPOLOGETIC.
HE TOLD ME THE "NEW YORK TIMES"
MIGHT BE NEXT ON HIS LIST.
IF THEY ARE NOT INC. FAIR, IF I
DON'T LIKE WHAT THEY ARE
WRITING, I WILL TAKE A BAD
STORY, BUT IF I THINK IT IS
UNFAIR OR INACCURATE, I HAVE THE
RIGHT TO CUT THEM OFF AS A
CANDIDATE.
MARK: I KNOW SOME OF HIS
SUPPORTERS LIKE IT, BUT ISN'T
THIS AN ATTEMPT TO INTIMIDATE
REPORTERS FROM WRITING NEGATIVE
STORIES?
JIM: ALL OF MY EXPERIENCE AS A
REPORTER WOULD SAY YES, BUT WITH
DONALD TRUMP, I NEVER KNOW
BECAUSE HE DEFINITELY SEEMS TO
BE, THERE'S A MOTION INVOLVED
AND HE SEEMS TO GET ANGRY AND IT
SEEMS GENUINE AT THE SAME TIME,
BUT HE IS ALSO A SHOWMAN.
I DON'T KNOW.
JOHN: YOU ASKED HIM WHETHER HE
WOULD IMPOSE SIMILAR KINDS OF
BANDS IF HE WERE ELECTED
PRESIDENT.
TRUMP CAME BACK AND SAYS THAT IS
DIFFERENT FROM ME TAKING
SOMETHING AWAY.
I'M TAKING SOMETHING AWAY WHERE
I AM REPRESENTING THE NATION.
IT WAS HARD TO OURS WHAT HE WAS
SAYING, BUT HE'S SAYING I WILL
BE DIFFERENT WHEN I'M PRESIDENT.
HE SAID THESE ARE EVENTS HELD ON
PUBLIC PROPERTY, ETC..
D HAVE ANY SENSE THAT WE SHOULD
LEAVE HIM THAT HE WOULD ONLY BE
A DIFFERENT PERSON AND WOULD NOT
TRY TO INTIMATE THE PRESS?
JIM: WHAT'S THE LINE IN THE
STOCK COMMERCIALS -- PAST
PERFORMANCE IS NOT INDICATIVE OF
FUTURE RESULTS?
YOU GUYS HAVE A STORY TODAY
WHERE REPUBLICANS IN THE SENATE
SAY WE THOUGHT AFTER HE WAS THE
PRESUMED NOMINEE THAT HE WOULD
CHANGE HIS BEHAVIOR.
THAT IS A CASE WHERE HE SAID HE
WAS GOING TO GET SO PRESIDENTIAL
WE WOULDN'T BELIEVE IT AND HE
DID IT.
WHAT HE MEANT TO SAY IS I'M
REPRESENTING THE NATION, NOT
MYSELF.
MARK: WOULD YOU LIKE TO SEE
OTHER NEWS ORGANIZATIONS SAY IF
WE ARE IN SOLIDARITY, WE WON'T
COVER YOU?
JIM: WE SHOULD HAVE SOLIDARITY,
HE SHOULD LET THE POST COVER HIM
AND WE SHOULD ALL MAKE A LOT OF
NOISE ABOUT IT.
AT THE SAME TIME, WE CANNOT CUT
OFF COVERING THE PRESUMED
NOMINEE OF THE PARTY.
IF A THIRD-PARTY CANDIDATE SHOWS
UP, YOU HAVE TO COVER HIM.
IF OUR CREDENTIALS ARE TAKEN
AWAY, SO BE IT.
I SUPPORT THE POST PERSONALLY.
MARK: DO YOU SUBSCRIBE?
JIM: I DO SUBSCRIBE.
JOHN: DO YOU HAVE ANY SENSE THAT
WHEN HE THREATENS JEFF BEZOS
THAT HE MAY BE OVER THE LINE?
JIM: I THINK IT'S CHILLING.
I TOLD HIM THAT AND THAT'S WHY I
TITLED THE COLUMN "BRRR."
JOHN: THANKS FOR STOPPING BY.
WE WILL BE RIGHT BACK.
♪
MARK: YOU LOVE POLLS, WE'VE GOT
POLLS.
GO TO OUR WEBSITE, BLOOMBERG
POLITICS.COM.
COMING UP, EMILY CHANG TALKS TO
THE CEO OF K2 INTERACTIVE AND
THE PRESIDENT OF NINTENDO
AMERICA.
"WITH ALL DUE RESPECT" IS BACK
TOMORROW.
SEE YOU THEN.
SAYONARA.
♪
MARK: I'M MARK CRUMPTON.
YOU ARE WATCHING "BLOOMBERG
WEST." EGYPT'S AVIATION
ADMINISTRATION SAYS IT HAS
ROTTED WRECKAGE OF THE AIRPLANE
THAT CRASHED INTO THE
MEDITERRANEAN LAST MONTH.
THE PLANE DISAPPEARED FROM RADAR
ON ROUTE TWO CAIRO FROM PARIS.
A NEW POLL SHOWS HILLARY CLINTON
OPENING UP A DOUBLE-DIGIT LEAD
OVER REPUBLICAN DONALD TRUMP.
50% OF THOSE SURVEYED SAID THEY
WOULD NEVER VOTE FOR TRUMP.
BY 50 TO 45 MARGIN, VOTERS SAY
TRUMP WOULD DO A BETTER JOB
FIGHTING TERRORISM.
CONNECTICUT DEMOCRAT CHRIS
MURPHY LAUNCH THE FILIBUSTER TO
FORCE A VOTE ON GUN CONTROL
LEGISLATION.
SENATOR MURPHY: HAVING COME
THROUGH THE EXPERIENCE OF
NEWTOWN, I'VE HAD ENOUGH.
IT HAS BEEN FOUR YEARS.